[Music]
paul benowitz lived next to a large air
force base when he saw colored lights in
the sky he assumed they were
experimental aircraft then he started
picking up strange radio signals that
seemed to be an alien language he took
his findings to the air force publicly
they denied the ufo alien story but
privately they confirmed paul's findings
the air force even funded his ufo
research he spent several years
gathering evidence and reporting it to
the authorities then he ended up in a
mental institution
let's find out why
[Music]
in 1969 while pursuing his phd in
physics paul bennowitz started a
successful electronics company in new
mexico called thunder scientific no
that's a pretty badass name for a
company it is
i know who it is
paul benowitz's primary clients were the
air force and nasa he did so much
business with the air force that he
actually bought a home and established a
lab right next to kirtland air force
base in albuquerque now kirtland is a
big facility it's one of the largest air
force installations in the country it
has science labs weapons testing areas
observatories and huge storage
facilities for nuclear weapons from the
second floor deck of his house paul
frequently saw strange colored lights in
the sky around the air force base lights
that were moving too fast to be aircraft
now paul documented and filmed
everything he saw
then paul benowitz had an idea he was an
engineer a physicist and an expert in
electronics so he set up his radio
equipment and detected transmissions on
a frequency in the gigahertz range much
higher than the military used at that
time as a pilot and military contractor
paul benowitz knew what air force
signals sounded like but this was
something very different he analyzed
these signals and realized they were
data bursts and in the data were
messages
but the air force has said time and time
again this is a quote from richard
horner assistant secretary of the air
force for research and development
all but a small percentage of these
reports
of unidentified flying objects have been
definitely attributed to natural
phenomena
that are neither mysterious nor dire end
quote what about that i'll answer that
but i'd like to make several points
doing it in 1947 the air technical
intelligence center at dayton the top
air force intelligence men and
scientists under contract sent a secret
document to the commanding general of
the air force saying that whatever these
things were they were real
in 1948 atic the same group
sent a top-secret estimate
to the commanding general point
vandenberg said these were
interplanetary spaceships
in 1952 there was an intelligence
analysis of the maneuvers of these
things
as seen by radar
triangulation radar photo
photographs and in 53
the central intelligence agency and the
air force had a special panel of
scientists meets the pentagon
to tell him what to do
and after they got through this group
said you don't have proof that these
things exist not scientific proof
but you have a very strong
circumstantial case we suggest you
quadruple investigations set up special
observation post in the meantime release
everything you've got the american
people and they have been spending a lot
of money investigating flying saucers
if they don't exist
why the money why do the intelligence
teams rush out every time there's a
sighting the databurst paul benowitz
received had noticeable patterns the
paul couldn't make sense of the data
manually but he did have access to an
early home computer and using an
operating system and software he wrote
himself he fed the alien broadcast to
the computer at first the messages were
nonsense so paul deployed a very old but
effective crypto analyst trick context
he told his program to assume that the
messages would have words like ship base
air water and time that worked yeah but
how do you learn to speak aliens so you
can translate it into english good
question you don't you use the computer
to put everything in context for example
let's say we knew the transmission had
something to do with making coffee you
tell the computer the context you have
it look for patterns that coincide with
beans water sugar milk and so on and
once you have the main patterns you can
expand to phrases used less frequently
like grind brew and drink eventually you
have a pretty good syntax you don't know
what the exact words are but you do know
what they mean
paul's first translations were almost
meaningless but he kept at it and
eventually had a general idea of what
the messages were saying his translation
wasn't perfect but it was good enough to
give him an idea of what the aliens
wanted and why they were here then he
did something i'd consider ill-advised
using the language he decoded he sent
his own message on that same frequency
and shortly after that he received a
reply this was the first message paul
decoded round ground women of earth are
needed flexible the next discharges our
ship our women do not command the north
among us you have many friends water
very short resist all attempts of
adoration listen orange make peace
sounds peaceful enough the women of
earth are needed is kind of ominous
here's the next message victory
our bases obtain supplies from the
starship metal time is yanked time is
yet
message hit star
using rejuvenation methods got us in
trouble
six sky we realized tell you all might
help you
all your base up along to us it does
kind of sound like that and there are
lots of these messages this one is
interesting take fast portion universe
against our aggression the number of our
crash saucers is eight wherever we
realize tell the truth
jump
jump opposite
alien forces me no help to you
that'll become invisible
keeping change we will not join sides
with anyone but our race is dying on the
home planet
paul benowitz now had the first two-way
communication with an alien civilization
he suspected that they were not here for
good reasons so he used this
communication to try and learn their
intentions and hopefully find
vulnerabilities through many messages
back and forth paul did learn the
alien's intentions
they weren't good
paul bennowitz learned that the alien's
homeworld was dying and there were
multiple alien races on earth many of
them look like the typical grey alien
with large eyes but there's also a race
of homo sapien aliens that look just
like us but better looking valiant
exactly
link below now at this point paul
benowitz was convinced an invasion was
imminent and people had to be warned he
prepared a dossier of his theory and
findings and went to the air force
paul was a veteran and trusted military
contractor so he was granted a meeting
bennutz was adamant that americans be
warned right away so they could prepare
and defend themselves they thought he
was in that case didn't they nope the
government took him very seriously the
base commander brought in the air force
office of special investigation or osi
to review paul's work and they were
impressed agent richard doty was
assigned to paul's case
doty visited paul's house and reviewed
all the film radio equipment and
everything that paul was using to
document and communicate with the aliens
the air force agreed to fund paul's
research as long as he delivered his
findings directly to them and he agreed
paul benowitz went to work with the help
of the air force and specifically agent
richard doty paul was convinced he could
gather enough intel to defeat the aliens
and save the human race
you believe in part that the movie's et
close encounters of the third kind we're
not entirely just the creative products
of some hollywood director that maybe
there's more to that why don't you
explain they were carefully
guided by representatives from mj-12 who
is this organization that is in charge
of the cover-up in order to get us ready
for the release of the information that
there are indeed aliens and in both
those movies they used small little
creatures and in order to get us ready
for this release of information so to
prepare us that the idea of benevolent
aliens from outer space are going to
help us unfortunately
they're not
they're not so benevolent so they made a
probably one of the most disastrous
mistakes when e.t was put out at that
time was before we discovered what i
call the double cross
or the grand deception
and they were trying to get us used to
the benevolent little creatures
but that isn't the case in the late
1970s and early 80s bill moore was a
rising star in the ufo community in 1980
he released a book called the roswell
incident until more came along nobody
really knew much about roswell or cared
about it but moore's book would bring
roswell back into the public eye and
almost all the details we know about the
roswell ufo crash come from his book
when bill moore asked paul benowitz if
they could meet of course paul said yes
the two men became friends and met every
few months for the next year and during
that year paul complained that he sent a
tremendous amount of data to the air
force every week and nothing was coming
of it then in 1981 bill moore gave paul
benowitz a secret government file called
project aquarius dated a year earlier
when paul read the document he couldn't
believe it the 7602 air force
intelligence group was analyzing all of
paul's data but never told him this was
proof that the air force was taking him
seriously but why lied to him about it
then bill moore said very carefully and
very quietly paul you'd better be very
careful with what you do with this use
it for your own research but otherwise
just sit on it now the last paragraph of
the aquarius document is this the
official us government policy and
results of project aquarius is still
classified top secret with no
dissemination outside official
intelligence channels and with
restricted access to mg12 case on
benwitz is being monitored by nasa inens
who request all future evidence be
forwarded to them through afosi
ivod because of a chance of public
exposure did that thing just mention
mj-12 yep bill moore and paul benowitz
had no idea what this was this was the
first time majestic 12 appeared in a
document and if you want a full episode
on majestic 12 email me or let me know
in the comments but in short majestic 12
is a group of 12 people who control the
flow of information all the information
about ufos every sighting investigation
and even the slightest mention of the
ufo majestic 12 is notified and only
majestic 12 could decide how to proceed
now paul being a pilot started doing
flyovers of where he thought the
underground base was archuleta mesa near
dulce new mexico he took pictures of
domes vents going underground and saw
huge towers and he put all the photos in
his reports and this would continue for
several years but then something scary
happened in monitoring the alien
transmissions it appeared that there was
a relationship or agreement between the
aliens and the united states government
but that relationship broke down on
paul's next flight he saw scorched
patches of ground flattened trees and
even downed aircraft it was as if a
battle had taken place over dulce now if
america was to win a war with the aliens
it would need a new weapon and a
strategy fortunately paul benowitz had
both
[Music]
the united states army presents
the big picture
an official report produced for the
armed forces and the american people
fantasy
not at all
what you see on the screen at this
moment and we'll see in greater detail a
bit later in this film
is a glimpse of the united states army
in the years that lie just ahead of us
this is a report on the army's effort to
prepare for the challenges of that
future
it is a report on the army's effort
to achieve a sharper sword and stronger
shield with which it can do its assigned
part in preserving the peace or if
necessary defending the nation and the
free world against whatever enemy might
rise against it
using the huge amounts of information he
intercepted from the alien transmissions
paul benowitz created a document called
project beta project beta included the
alien takeover plan and a strategy to
defeat them and a weapon we can use
against them he even built a working
prototype of this energy weapon project
beta said that the aliens have abducted
conservatively three hundred thousand
americans and they've all been implanted
with devices and returned to the general
population and these implants turned
every human into a walking camera and
microphone and the implants can be used
to create false memories seize control
of the mind or even switch the brain off
altogether and experiments were being
done in the base under dulce horrific
genetic experiments like splicing alien
dna with humans and paul benowitz sent
project beta to his senators and other
elected officials even to the president
of the united states the only reply he
got was a standard form letter that said
project blue book has been closed and
the air force no longer investigates
ufos paul knew this was a lie he had the
project aquarius document that proved it
the only thing that made sense was that
the government was compromised it could
be that senior military officials
politicians and even the president
himself could have been implanted and
over the next couple of years paul
benowitz became more and more frustrated
and paranoid when bill moore and richard
doty paid him a visit to check on his
mental state it wasn't good paul kept
knives and guns all over the house he
insisted that he was being watched and
followed all the time he lost so much
weight that he looked ill and he was
smoking a full pack of cigarettes every
hour he said the aliens were coming into
his house at night injecting him with
something that made him drive out into
the desert then he'd be back home with
no recollection of what happened both
bill moore and richard doty said they
saw needle marks on his arm by now bill
moore richard doty and all paul's
friends were telling him to stop to
leave it alone paul's family begged him
to stop they wanted him to destroy all
the equipment and go back to focusing on
his business but paul wouldn't do it his
research was too important paul's mental
health continued to decline he didn't
trust anyone around him he thought his
wife had an alien implant his children
had to take over his business he became
so paranoid that one day he barricaded
himself in his house and covered every
door and window with sandbags his family
had seen enough they committed paul to a
psychiatric facility after multiple
hospitalizations paul benowitz died in
2003 at the age of 75. he spent the last
25 years of his life paranoid obsessed
and in mental agony because he could not
get anyone to believe what he knew about
the aliens even with all the evidence it
literally drove him insane but what's
really sad is
none of it was necessary because the
entire story about the aliens the secret
base the transmissions the genetic
experiments the abductions the plot to
take over the world all of it was a lie
it was all a made-up story fed to him by
richard doty and the united states
government oh you gotta be freaking
kidding me
[Music]
the air force office of special
investigation or osi has a couple of
purposes one of those is
counterintelligence a common technique
of counterintelligence is disinformation
when paul benoit's intercepted signals
from kirtland air base he didn't really
think they were aliens not at first he
was concerned that if he could detect
transmissions from the base then anyone
could including soviet spies
and after reviewing paul's equipment and
research in detail the air force
realized that paul was right the signals
were coming from the base and were
vulnerable that's a problem when the air
force reviewed paul's photos in film the
objects that seemed to be ufos were
actually secret experimental aircraft
that's another problem but rather than
tell paul benowitz the truth which
according to the air force would
compromise security special agent
richard doty was given an assignment
feed paul benowitz information to lead
him to believe that he discovered a
hostile alien presence why not just tell
him to back off because the air force
didn't know who paul's friends were if
paul was compromised by a soviet agent
the soviets would know there were secret
projects happening on the base so the
air force would go a different way now
at first this was just a simple nod from
dodie all i had to do was say well you
know what paw
maybe what you did see was ufos so
nothing very specific but over time the
lies doty told paul became more detailed
and other government agencies got in on
the action at some point paul was sure
he was being watched from the vacant
house across the street it was easy to
say this was paul's paranoia and not
take him seriously but paul was right
the national security agency was
surveilling him from that house and to
make things even worse the alien
transmissions that paul decoded they
were actually sent from the nsa
the nsa also swapped out paul's computer
to ensure that he would decode the
messages the way they wanted him to see
them it was all fake and paul benowitz
ate it up and suffered because of it
paul was a victim of the government's
counterintelligence plan but he wasn't
the only one
[Music]
look we've established in history and
documents through the freedom of
information act the cia and the military
complex as a whole has really aimed to
essentially mislead the public when it
comes to ufos tell them something that
necessarily is not the truth we've seen
it time and time again through the
decades over and over and over when
author bill moore's celebrity within the
ufo community was at its peak he was
contacted by someone in government
intelligence we now know that was
richard doty doty offered bill moore a
deal moore would receive government
documents on ufos and learn what the
government was hiding but in exchange he
would disseminate dodi's fake ufo
stories and report on people within the
ufo community
dodie wanted to know who the ufo
enthusiasts were and what they knew the
fear was that if paul benowitz could
intercept secret military data then
other people could now it's never been
confirmed but it's believed that during
this time the united states was building
and testing either stealth or drone
technology at kirtland air base this was
information that absolutely could not
fall into an enemy's hands so this is
how paul bennowitz came to know bill
moore it was a setup moore was given the
aquarius document and instructed to give
it to paul but here's where the counter
intel campaign starts to get sloppy bill
moore had seen the aquarius document of
course he was fascinated by it and at
that time moore thought the information
and documents he was getting were
legitimate but when moore was given the
aquarius document to forward to paul
benowitz it was different details were
changed doty brushed off moore's
concerns he said the document was
sanitized and redacted for security
reasons moore didn't believe it
obviously the plan was to get paul to go
public with the aquarius document then
the government steps in to discredit him
this meant moore was now specifically
being asked to lie to a fellow ufo
researcher on behalf of the us
government a man he considered a friend
and helped the government destroy his
friend's reputation moore was conflicted
so he didn't do anything not for months
then dodi told him deliver the document
or never hear from me again so moore did
as he was told and delivered the
fraudulent project aquarius document but
trying to protect him he begged paul to
never speak of it so special agent doty
had paul benowitz covered on the
kirtland air base side but he still
needed to address the issue of
underground bases near dulce that paul
was convinced he saw so doty and the osi
put props all around the area they set
up domes and air vents and even what
looked like alien craft they littered
the mountain with the stuff the osi had
helicopters painted black
and flew them at locations and times
where paul was sure to see them and paul
believed it all when you consider all
the time and trouble and expense that
went into deceiving paul benowitz you
have to ask who ordered this and why was
it just to discredit one ufo guy
no richard dodie's actual goal was to
infiltrate the ufo community and flood
that community with as much
disinformation as possible then the
government could observe the results of
that campaign identify possible security
risks and if necessary neutralize them
but all of this would eventually unravel
and the truth would be revealed
the mutual ufo network or mufon holds a
convention every year in 1989 bill moore
was a speaker at that convention and
during his talk he admitted that the us
government had been actively spreading
lies about ufos for years and he knew
this because he was helping them to do
it
and it was richard doty
then with afosi at kirkland air force
base
who soon came into play as the middleman
in that process
shortly thereafter
it became apparent to me that my
supplying information to the government
through dodi
on the activities of paul benowitz
april
and to a lesser extent several other
individuals
was to be a part of this equation
[Music]
i also discovered that whatever it was
that benowitz was involved with
he was the subject of considerable
interest on the part of not one but
several government agencies
and that they were actively trying to
defuse him by pumping as much
mis-disinformation through him
as he could possibly absorb
he was practically booed off the stage
frankly i'm a little ashamed
of some people in this audience
regardless of what you believe what you
hear or not it was really hard for these
people to learn that everything they
believed regarding ufos was a lie and
this confession ended bill moore's
career in ufo research
bill moore said that he was one of
several high-profile ufo personalities
who had made deals with dodie though he
never revealed the names he also said
dodie was feeding disinformation to
tabloids like the national enquirer and
to journalists like linda molten howe
the disinformation campaign developed by
the air force osi and executed by agent
richard doty was a success there were
now so many wild stories circulating
about ufos that it was impossible for
actual earnest research to cut through
the noise another goal of the campaign
was to marginalize believers make it so
mainstream scientists and politicians
and reporters would never publicly admit
to believing in ufos the stories were
too crazy the only people publicly
discussing ufos were what you'd call
fringe conspiracy nuts this is exactly
what the government wanted but here's
the thing the key to a successful
disinformation campaign is staying as
close to the truth as possible so of all
the crazy ufo information that richard
doty spread how much of it is true
well according to richard doty himself
almost all of it
[Music]
i'm richard doty
i was assigned as a special agent with
the air force office of special
investigations
at curling air force base
i was a counterintelligence officer at
the base
and one of my jobs uh was to conduct
counterintelligence operations
uh at the base
and uh during my time there my first few
months there i was briefed into a
special access program
involving the u.s government's
uh
investigation and contacts with
extraterrestrial the visitation
of these extraterrestrials to to uh to
earth
i was writing project
into the project in the summer of 1979.
and and and the briefing was
it was a special access program
i had a special security clearance to
have access to it
and it was brief i was briefed into it
by an air force colonel
from washington who came down and
briefed myself and a couple other people
into this program they showed us a uh
the movie they actually showed us this
i believe a 16 millimeter movie on their
recovery
uh it was obviously the movie was
classified highly classified their
narrator in the movie uh detailed uh
when the crash occurred approximately
when the crash occurred in in the latter
part of june of 1947
and uh and and the recovery uh showing a
military person off the
recovery site uh
uh just uh recovering the bodies at the
site
and the uh craft that was at that site
the story of air force osi agent richard
doty is a complicated one and because he
worked in military intelligence it's not
easy to find information after the paul
bennowitz affair he stayed in the air
force but left the office of special
investigation he said some of his
superiors saw his actions as
unauthorized so he was asked to leave
which he did voluntarily and there's
nothing in his military record to
indicate he's not telling the truth
after he left the service in 1988 his
life gets confusing he became a new
mexico state policeman eventually
retiring from that position but
something changed in him he became a ufo
believer doty continues to show up in
interviews in documentaries even goes to
ufo conventions in the early 1980s
richard doty did more damage to ufo
research than any single person ever had
but as recently as a few years ago he's
a guest speaker at ufo conventions he
claims 80 percent of the information
circulating about ufos is real he claims
the roswell crash happened he claims the
us government did recover a spacecraft
did recover alien bodies and even had a
live alien at los alamos for a few years
that alien by the way liked tibetan
music and strawberry ice cream oh hold
on did you just say aliens like
strawberry ice cream yup i'll take
sentences i thought i'd never hear for
200 alex dodie said when he was briefed
into osi he was shown a film with clips
from the late 40s and early 50s that
showed all these things were true
but can we trust him
[Music]
the craft is wasn't it was it more or
less an over egg-shaped craft it wasn't
uh saucer shaped
but the creatures were approximately
four foot they had didn't appear to have
any ears the fingers had no thumbs just
four four fingers suction devices under
tips of their fingers
and they found
a number of different objects in the
craft that they used
they experimented with and found
uh they had a piece of they thought was
plexiglas
it was a square p a rectangular piece of
that they had they kept
for years before they figured out it was
an end the energy device for the
craft
if you follow richard dodie's interviews
through the years you'll notice the
details aren't consistent now maybe
that's just a product of getting older
but what about his job history he worked
for the air force specifically spreading
lies about ufos then he became a
policeman he talks about these things
easily but i've never seen him mention
that he spent 10 years as a contractor
for hal put off i won't go into detail
about put off here but for those who
don't know he's the founder of to the
stars a private venture that
investigates ufos
fine who else is on the board of to the
stars well there's christopher mellon of
the melon family and when not enjoying
life as a billionaire chris worked for
the cia and the department of defense
who else steve justice former director
of advanced systems development at
lockheed martin the infamous skunk works
division he's led many secret military
projects but good luck finding
information on him then you have luis
alessandro a former intelligence officer
who ran the secret government project
atip the advanced aerospace threat
identification program atip was
essentially a continuation of project
blue book a military program to
investigate ufos the government denied
atip's existence until the new york
times exposed it this private company
that says they are bringing ufos
mainstream sure has a lot of senior
people from the american intelligence
apparatus and they hire people like
richard doty foot soldiers of that
apparatus have all these people had
changes of heart they spent their entire
careers executing covert operations
against american citizens and spreading
lies to people who simply want the truth
but that was then they say you can trust
us now the new york times exposed secret
government programs related to ufos the
navy has released footage of pilots
tracking ufos but how much more do we
really know the government recently
released an enormous amount of documents
pertaining to ufos congress had a public
hearing about ufos how much more do we
really know not much was richard dodie
lying then is he lying now who knows
because of a decades-long
government-sponsored disinformation
campaign a campaign that i believe is
still happening we don't know what to
believe but that was the point all along
the government has thousands of square
miles of land in the middle of nowhere
but it flies secret aircraft right near
paul benowitz's house in albuquerque
paul benowitz didn't receive any
mysterious signals until after agent
dodie inspected and photographed the
equipment he was using then suddenly the
nsa shows up and beams alien messages
into paul's house these are not
coincidences
the air force put out irresistible bait
and paul benowitz bill moore and
countless others swallowed it they are
victims we all are victims of our own
government our military our law
enforcement our elected officials all of
them solemnly swear to uphold the
constitution and protect the united
states of america from all enemies both
foreign and domestic but who are they
really swearing to protect not all of us
because that oath doesn't seem to apply
to the individual american citizen no
matter how honest you are how loyal how
patriotic or how many years you spent
serving your country if you interfere
even slightly with the government's
agenda your own government will dedicate
a tremendous amount of resources to
destroy your reputation your finances
your career and if it can your sanity
and call it a success your government
will take away all that you hold dear in
the name of the greater good how many
lives have been sacrificed at the holy
altar of protecting national security
how many victims
isn't it time we demanded an answer
well don't do it because otherwise the
next victim is you
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y files if you had fun
or learn anything do me a favor and like
subscribe comment and share i know it's
annoying to ask but that stuff actually
really helps and special thanks to our
patreon members who make this channel
possible i couldn't do it without you
and if you'd like to support the y files
consider becoming a patreon member it's
cheap and you get lots of perks or buy
something from the wi-fi store links
below that's gonna do it until next time
be safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you